What do you think about Adhd?
I have it.
I'm frustrated by my failures
in life because of it.
I am trying to become a a chemist
and I am failing at school.
Um,
I think ADHD is a catch all diagnosis.
I think that people who are extroverted
and unconscientious for example,
often manifest the traits of,
of uh,
attention deficit disorder.
Um,
I know that there isn't any real evidence
of longterm utility and cycle and
cycle.
What a psycho pharmacological
treatment for Adhd.
Um,
I would say though,
if you are having a hard time
concentrating on your goals,
that what you should probably do is
set yourself up with a therapist,
find someone you can talk to,
you know,
so see two or three therapists.
I know it's expensive but
so is not having a life.
Find someone you can talk to and
then make it and someone practical,
probably a behavioral
therapist would be best.
And then have them set goals with you
and help you strategize to stay on track
week to week.
That's the best thing.
Or to set that up with a friend if
he can't do it with the therapist.
So that's,
that's the best advice I have for that.
And keep at it,
man.
You know,
but break your,
you gotta learn to schedule.
You got to learn to break your days down
into disciplined subsections and you've
got to practice out at and practice at it.
And,
um,
there isn't an easier
answer that I know of,
but having someone that will
help keep your responsible,
I think can be useful.
I've seen that be useful for
people who have attention deficits,
disorder,
let's say.